pourquoi contre les indes est drôle
c'est ça chaque fois qu'on parle du amal
à fond dit on est contre les hommes ont
dit vous nous parlez leur verdict ce si
c'est pas vrai on ne prenait pas les
femmes en est absolument
de toute façon la moitié des bonnes
femmes à vivre avec un bonhomme dont
alors joueurs importants seraient contre
les hommes sol
[Musique]
sous l'arc de triomphe à paris repose le
soldat inconnu représentant symbolique
des militaires morts pour la france
chaque soir depuis 1923 la flamme qui le
surplombe est ravivée puis un jour un
homme sur deux est une femme peut-on
lire sur des banderoles le 26 70 12
femmes tentent en effet de déposer une
gerbe à plus inconnu que le soldat
inconnu sa femme
du coup on les embarque les journaux en
parlent le mlf est née officiellement
mais une question se pose est-ce que
vous savez ce qu'est le mouvement de
libération de la femme
alors d'abord c'est le mouvement de
libération des femmes et ensuite la fin
c'est qu'ils en ont assez que les maris
commandes toujours oui alors c'est un
peu réducteur moi j'aurais plutôt dit
que des femmes se manifeste par ce
qu'elle voyait que les hommes ils sont
peinards dans leurs fauteuils regarde la
télé si le vent cette prise de
conscience collective alors largement
médiatisé est en fait le produit de
groupes plus modestes qui agissait déjà
j'ai fondé dès 1967 avec une autre femme
un petit groupe qui s'appelait fema et
qui étaient mixtes d'ailleurs et en 70
c'est la collection des petits groupes
qui travaillait dans leur coin qui s'est
réuni pour donner le mouvement de
libération des femmes des points de
départ différent mais des revendications
communes
l'égalité hommes femmes dans le travail
et les tâches domestiques la liberté des
femmes à disposer de leur corps l'accès
libre et gratuit à l'avortement
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et notamment le viol c'est la
guerre des sexes existent ce n'est pas
nous qui l'avons déclaré
qu'est ce que c'est le féminise il en
montre certaines horreurs pour mieux les
dépasser
et pour mieux aller vers un avenir
serein dans un premier temps les
réunions du mlf sont réservés aux femmes
et même si cette mesure se veut
provisoire très vite les hommes veulent
se joindre au mouvement
avec parfois une grosse motivation
pourquoi les gemmes ne contribue pas
comme les femmes
à la libération le gilet noir ne peuvent
pas participer à un tirage est
complètement con bref les militants du
mlf investissent l'espace publique et
manifeste
elles écrivent et dessine aussi plus
aucun sujet de société n'est abordée
sans que la question des femmes
deviennent centrale mais on ne peut pas
poser la question de l'égalité quand on
reconnaît qu'il ya de sexe différent à
ce moment là il faut dire deux pères
deux individus équivalent mais comme
tout combat aussi juste soit ils les
militantes sont confrontés à des
oppositions parfois surprenantes
un délai qui qu'est ce que ça vous
faisait à l'époque d'être défini
pardonnez moi l'expression comme sa loge
mal baisées virago c'est dans l'ordre
des choses je crois que le féminisme
dans ces manifestations a toujours été
accompagnés de la caricature qu'on en a
fait c'est à dire on nous ne pouvons pas
émergé 50 caricature s'il est vrai qu'au
siècle dernier le terme virago désigné
de manière péjorative une femme avec des
allures d'homme aujourd'hui préférons
lui sa définition originelle qui désigne
une femme forte et courageuse c'est très
bien parce qu'autrefois on était trop
malheureux et j'espère que les femmes
sont plus heureuses que ma génération
oui c'est notamment en martelant
quelques messages simples que la
condition féminine avance le combat que
des féministes peut-être un combat
violent violent au niveau des idées sans
doute pour certains et même pour
certaines qui semble subir le mouvement
comme un véritable affront
car actuellement le mlf et qu'une
mauvaise image de marque pour la femme
et lorsque vous arrivez comme moi à me
battre envers un homme est la première
réflexion qui vous fait ou alan pied
arrêtés mais laisse la première
souvent moqué craint ou incompris le mlf
a néanmoins pesé sur toutes les
décisions concernant les femmes ou la
famille plus aucun débat n'a eu lieu
sans une représentante du mlf
au début ça agace mais au final ça
avance et puis il faut quand même
rappeler que ce mouvement via a permis
aux femmes de passer du moyen-âge à
l'ère moderne une nouvelle ère
parfaitement résumé par ses jeunes
comédiennes de talent e mail of sunday
existe plus c'est ce machin où il ya des
femmes se fini maintenant
maintenant elles ont obtenu ce qu'elle
voulait l'avortement est libre il ya la
pilule vous croyez que sa soeur il ya
quelque chose le mlf
quelle est la qualité que vous préférez
chez une femme la réserve est loin de
s'être réservé quelques années plus tard
les 100 ans du mlf coule toujours dans
les carburateurs de la société en 2003
né le mouvement ni [ __ ] ni soumises
afin d'entreprendre des actions
concrètes contre les violences faites
aux femmes
c'est un mouvement mixte populaire et
féministe j'ai l'impression qu'on a deux
catégories de jeunes femmes il de femmes
celles qui se battent pour la parité qui
à celles qui se battent pour survivre
celles qui habitent en cité je pense
qu'il faut encore le répéter que quand
une famille menacée
c'est toute la société qui est menacée
merci
le mouvement a pour but de dénoncer
l'insécurité dans les quartiers mais
s'étend rapidement à toutes les rues et
même à l'europe
rencontrant les mêmes oppositions que le
mlf il ya ceux qui veulent pas en
entendre parler qui pense que c'est même
pas la peine parce qu'on est en train de
toucher leurs privilèges aussi et parce
qu'on est en train de faire exploser les
l'omerta et toutes les questions tabous
dans les quartiers en 2008 un autre
mouvement se crée et son ampleur est
désormais mondiale les femen et ses
seins nus qu'elle lance la bataille pour
le droit des femmes
chaque mouvement apporte une avancée
notable en cassant les codes et les
préjugés de l'époque qui l'a fait naître
pour manifester verts habillés tout
simplement besoin de se dévêtir comme ça
c'est pourtant comme ça qu'elle
manifeste comme ça que le monde les
connaît et comme ça qu'elles captent
l'attention et font passer leur message
aujourd'hui
n'écoute pas la parole des femmes ce qui
les intéresse les femmes et ça on l'a
compris on n'a pas d'autre choix pour ce
faire antoine donc regardez moi je suis
nue ça n'a rien de sexuel et le regard
des premières militants du mlf sur les
femen démontre une certaine continuité
idéologique
ici elle voulait rendre hommage à la
femme du soldat inconnu
parmi les manifestantes sur l'image à
droite cathy berne m quarante ans après
elles regardent leur happening
déshabillé de ces jeunes consoeurs je
trouve qu'elles sont bien ces phénomènes
parce que est là pour faire le buzz unis
vont carrément quoi est elle vivons avec
les méthodes d'aujourd'hui du mlf au
phénomène
les années passent les méthodes évoluent
mais le fonds demeure un des slogans du
monde l'an de libération des femmes
c'est notre corps nous appartient le mlf
a créé une dynamique un soulèvement et
même un hymne
non
[Musique]